I want to talk about another angle to
this and then we're gonna move on from
the Trump and word tapes Fiasco with
every passing day almost with every
passing few hours we get closer to
confirming that Omarosa Manigault rump
is recorded saying horrible vile
disgusting things about black people
during tapings of The Apprentice is real
so we had number one the fact that
Omarosa claims Trump regularly used the
n-word and it's on tape to trump claim
that it's all lies and then three we had
this recording released where three
black Trump staffers appear to be
describing or discussing or debating how
to spin and provide context for
something really bad that Trump said we
then have as I told you just minutes ago
the press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders unwilling to deny that it's
possible Trump is on tape using the
n-word about black people and we now
have sort of like a fifth or sixth piece
to this entire fiasco which is an
interview with the Penn Jillette Penn
Jillette of Penn & Teller Fame I guess
they are the illusionist magicians I
don't know what word they use what's
what's some political commentary thrown
in there yeah political magicians I
don't know where you want to call him
Penn Jillette was a contestant on The
Apprentice the reality show Trump hosted
five years ago and he also now is saying
Trump would regularly say absolutely
horrible things during tapings and the
interview was published yesterday in
vulture and it's really bad and there's
a couple key parts that I'm going to
read to you one is where he is asked
does Mark Burnett have tapes of
President Trump saying damaging things
during Celebrity Apprentice and pence
says yeah I was in the room and when
he's asked can you tell me what you've
heard him say Penn said quote know if
Donald Trump could not become president
I would tell you all the stories but the
stakes are now high and I am an
unreliable narrator what I do as much as
anything as I'm a storyteller and story
tellers are liars so I can emotionally
tell you things that happened racially
sexually and that showed stupidity and
lack of compassion when I was in the
room with Donald Trump and I guarantee
you that I will get details wrong I
would not feel comfortable talking about
what I felt I saw in that room because
when I was on that show I was sleeping
four to five hours a night I was
uncomfortable stress is the wrong word
but I
not at my best then at the end of the
day they put you in a room and they
bring out a guy Trump who has no power
whatsoever
and he's capricious and petty he is
actually being upfront here which is
yeah he said this stuff but I might not
get every detail right and the trumpets
would latch on to any minor
insignificant detail I get wrong to try
to discredit the entire story I've never
been a big fan of Penn Jillette's in any
way I've never found his commentary
super interesting I've never really
cared for his act but I don't want to
cloud that I don't want to let that
cloud the reality that he's being very
precise he's been cautious here about
what he says and what he doesn't say and
I think big picture he's a force for
good here he's a force in favor of the
world of skepticism and he's done some
good things and I have no reason
whatsoever to think that he's being
dishonest here yeah I think he's right
here because human memory can get muddy
too right especially because this
happened several years ago sure that's
why you know like eyewitness accounts
aren't the best pieces of evidence but
it's also not a denial - he's not saying
that Trump never used the word
no and he is saying that the horrible
things were related to both race and
sexuality so that is once again sort of
along the lines of what Omarosa is
saying but let's cut through all of this
right cut through Penn's assertions cut
through the speculation and the
conjecture and let's get down to what
matters if we ultimately get audio of
Donald Trump throwing the N word around
would it make a difference
he said racially insensitive stuff the
entire campaign he made fun of disabled
people he slammed the parents of dead
military service members he talked about
his own penis size during debates he
talked about grabbing him by the [ __ ]
and assaulting women by using his
celebrity power and he won anyway right
people already voted for him despite his
regularly saying horrible things is it
really actually going to change anything
if there's an word tapes of Trump I
don't think so I don't think so either I
mean in an alternate universe where
Bernie Sanders is president and there's
a tape of him saying the n-word yeah
that could take him down to his
resignation but with Trump there's
already a track record of racism like
it's already baked in we already know
who Trump is yeah but Trump was a
Democrat when he
those things I can't say it with a
straight face last thing prepare for
Penn Jillette to be attacked to some
wacky left-wing liberal he's not he's a
longtime small government libertarian
he's associated with the right-wing
libertarian Cato Institute he's no
liberal they might try to smear him as
one but he's not and the last and most
important thing to consider why would
mark burnett the producer of The
Apprentice if he has these tapes not
have release them I can't think of any
good answers other than he knows or
suspected that they would have been
damaging to Trump and he wanted to
protect Trump and that's something that
should scare us all because I believe
that it would be his responsibility if
he had these recordings to put them out
there if there was the time to release
them it would have been in the heat of
the 2016 election cycle it may be
shortly after the Access Hollywood tapes
but we I don't know what his politics
are at the same time you know the best
time to plant the tree is 20 years ago
the second best time is today the best
time to release him would have been
before Trump was elected the next best
time is right now and I hope that he
does that if he's got him I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show fantastic program for
you today and I'm glad you're with us
this might come as a shock to you but
Vice President Mike Pence said that the
president should resign over his lies
about his adultery truly shocking
revelation except he didn't say it about
the current president when I mean that
Mike Pence said the president should
resign over his lies related to
infidelity he was talking about Bill
Clinton at the time apparently when it's
Trump it no longer matters and this is
the same Mike Pence who's so pious and
so moral and so Christian such a good
Christian that he won't have dinner
alone with another woman it needs to
have a chaperone there and there's been
a bunch of old columns by pence that
have come to light and of course he's
talking about Bill Clinton here but
wouldn't it apply five times more to
Donald Trump pence wrote who knows what
year if you fall and I fall into bad
moral habits we can harm our families
our employers and our friends the
President of the United States can
incinerate the planet seriously the very
idea that we ought to have at or less
than the same moral demands placed on
the chief executive that we place on our
next-door neighbor is
ludicrous and dangerous throughout our
history we have seen the presidency as
the repository of all our highest hopes
and ideals and values to demand less is
to do an injustice to the blood that
bought our freedoms and then the
goldmine calling for the resignation of
the president for lying about adultery
not this president the previous
president of course saying our leaders
must either act to restore the luster
and dignity of the institution of the
presidency or we can be certain that
this is only the beginning of an even
more difficult time for our land for the
nation to move on the president must
move out he's also on audio visual
recordings saying very similar things
take a look at this is adultery no
longer a big deal in Indiana and in
America and just love to know your
thoughts cuz I I for one believe that
the seventh commandment contained in the
Ten Commandments is still a big deal
it's the most important promise you'll
ever make
and holding people accountable to those
promises and holding people accountable
to respecting the promises that other
people make to me what what could
possibly be a bigger deal than that in
this country if only he would hold the
current president to that standard and I
point this out not to actually have a
conversation about hypocrisy but to
point out that it's all bs what I mean
is political positions public personas
political issues making something a big
deal or not a big deal this is all cover
for what we've seen happen bigger
picture in the United States for the
last 30 to 40 years which is that
corporations increasingly control
government and our lives and this is
sort of the other side to the Trump
Fiasco on the one hand we have to report
on the day to day of the Trump
administration the hypocrisy from
everyone around him like Mike Pence in
this clip the lies the corruption with
Russia the possible obstruction of
justice and crimes it's all real and
it's all happening but the backdrop is
that behind the micro of the political
theater is that the Trump administration
didn't just appear out of nowhere
we have a very flawed democracy and I
don't mean just like how we count votes
first-past-the-post
I mean our political system for decades
has been dominated by the false
dichotomy of Democrat versus Republican
when it's been two parties that allowed
corporate power to build where the
individual now barely counts and yes all
the time I tell you Democrats and
Republicans are different on many issues
what the minimum wage should be net
neutrality important differences and
we've got to vote the current regime out
in November but elected officials from
both parties for decades stand aside
they benefit from the status quo no one
gets the corporate and dark money out of
politics and I question of course
whether any of them want to since the
status quo got them elected and then the
majority of the political debate is
playing to the narrow debate where there
is no real questioning of the systems
that got us here at large campaign
finance yes that is a meta questioning
of the system and people are doing it
some people are doing it but not in a
way where the protests and the civil
disobedience are actually going to
change what's going on
how did Trump win the Republican primary
okay that's an important question do his
supporters realize that they've been
bamboozled maybe they do maybe they
don't
it matters but the big issue is how
corporate power has subjugated both
Democrats and Republicans none of that
would have changed whether it's Hillary
or Trump major consequences between
Hillary versus Trump which Wars will be
started how many lives will Trump ruin
but the status quo pushes ahead and this
pens hypocrisy about resignation based
on lying about infidelity it's just
another data point that it is all
political posturing 95% of what we hear
from our elected officials on both sides
is political posturing Pat there may be
tapes oh lordy it seems that there might
be tapes I haven't talked about this
story on the regular show because
there's been a lot of conjecture and a
lot of speculation but it is very
quickly becoming a real story and I do
want to talk about it now and it relates
to Omarosa Manigault our she recently
wrote a book one of these salacious
tell-all type books where she claims
that there are recordings of Donald
Trump using the n-word
this wouldn't be hugely surprising like
I I don't I don't know that many people
in our audience who
be shocked to hear tapes of Trump using
the n-word but Donald Trump has been
denying that he uses the n-word never
mind they're being recordings and
initially there was this very aggressive
smear campaign against Omarosa and it
worked pretty well because there was a
contradiction in her tell-all memoir
she said tapes exist of Trump using the
n-word but I haven't heard them more
recently she changed her mind and she
said oh I have heard the tapes and this
appeared to be a contradiction but she's
explained it by saying no when I you
know I wrote the book some time ago at
that point I hadn't heard the tapes now
I have heard the tapes and that's a
plausible enough explanation but this
hasn't stopped the Trump administration
and Trump himself from going into full
denial and smear mode calling Omarosa
all sorts of things
here's Trump on Twitter denying that he
has ever used the word the the n-word
that is just not in his vocabulary he
tweeted yesterday Mark Burnett called
he's the producer of The Apprentice to
say that there are no tapes of The
Apprentice where I used such a terrible
and disgusting word as attributed by
wacky and deranged Omarosa I don't have
that word in my vocabulary and I never
have she made it up look at her many
recent quotes okay and he goes on from
there but that's the relevant part so
now the narrative begins to fall apart
step one was yesterday
when a recording was leaked of Omarosa
being fired by White House chief of
staff John Kelly and that confirms
merely that recordings exist that
Omarosa has right all we learned from
that is that Omarosa has tapes and it's
not completely out of the realm of
possibility that she has more than one
tape people who record conversations
with others probably don't do it just
once so yes we at least know that it's
it's plausible that Omarosa has or has
access to tapes the big story happened
this morning where a recording was
released and what the recording
supposedly contains which I'm about to
play for you our trump staffers during
the campaign talking about how to manage
or spin
trump's use of the n-word CBS has
obtained this audio what we are told
this is
is a conversation involving Omarosa and
remember Katrina Pierson and other Trump
staffers figuring out how do we spin
what Trump said which is presumed to be
the n-word
take a listen then described a
conversation she had with then-candidate
Trump about making the slur so this is
just part a it's not proof that this was
about the n-word but it is about
something Trump said and the three
people involved here are I think we
determined Katrina Pierson is black
right it's true three of trumps black
staffers which of course again is not
proof of anything but the lies are
racking up because yesterday Katrina
Pierson claimed on Fox News that this
call never even took place that she
never participated in a call like this
and now 12 hours later we have audio of
the exact type of conversation that
Katrina Pierson that claimed never
happened so this is building pad and
slowly but surely in this drip drip drip
method we're getting closer to
confirmation of exactly what Omarosa is
claiming here yeah I mean everything
Elmer osis says you have to take with a
grain of salt especially now because
she's trying to sell her books yeah but
she said on Meet the Press that the tape
could be saved for an October Surprise
and I don't know if that's this October
or tomorrow morning 20 but yet that
would be highly damaging it could hurt
his poll numbers for a whole week and I
think your your point about what we'll
talk about the impact does this mean
Omarosa is a great person who we should
all love and trust no and she never
should have been working at the White
House but more and more elements of this
particular story are being proven true
in Trump's now furious at Omarosa which
is so funny because when you hire
someone that you know to be crazed
erratic
backstabber to work for you how are you
then shocked and angry when she ends up
being erratic and backstabbing you again
yeah he fired her three times on the
apprentice and then once from the White
House but Trump was supposed to hire the
best people that's not happening and I
actually am interested in how do you
spin like let's assume they're
discussing how to spin use of the n-word
how do you spin it you say he was
talking about the country of Niger it
was a conversation about African
diplomacy and he just had like a verbal
typo or a Freudian slip of some kind
he said [ __ ] he was quoting rap lyrics
right there was no ER on the end this
was merely him talking about the rap
songs it like ha what kind of context
can you even invent to make this
reasonable from Trump's usage there
would be no excuse for him saying it at
all but I mean the context would matter
like is he using it like how Bill Maher
use I don't think back verses and you
know an insulting way like there are
there are differences there context can
make it as we talked about yesterday on
the story about race baiting where mere
use of the n-word is not necessarily
racist discriminatory prejudicial
whatever Trump just doesn't have a
history of discussing race relations in
ways or I would imagine some benign
usage of the n-word last thing you can
tell how likely it is this is true by
how horrible the things Trump is saying
about Omarosa are and he's now calling
her a lowlife dog he treated this
tweeted this morning quote when you give
a crazed crying lowlife a break and give
her a job at the White House I guess it
just didn't work out good work by
general Kelly for quickly firing that
dog the more insulting Trump is the more
likely historically we've seen proven he
is to know that the allegations are true
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show will we ever get the N word
tapes do you think that they exist let
me know I am going to submit for your
review today what I believe could be the
most shameful moment of the Trump
administration so far and it's an
interview of Katrina Pierson appearing
on Fox News and straight-up lying to Ed
hen
his face repeatedly boldly confidently
about known facts that are on audio
recording so let me catch you up about
all this this relates to the Trump
n-word recordings which seem to be
bringing out the absolute worst pathetic
lying in everybody who's surrounding
Trump
it started when former Trump staffer
Omarosa Manigault rump using the n-word
when talking about black people and she
also specifically said that Trump
campaign advisor Katrina Pierson is on
one of these recordings talking about
how should they spin how can they spin
Donald Trump's use of the n-word Katrina
Pierson appeared on Fox News Monday
night I've already told you about this
and when she appeared on Monday night
she said no such tape exists no I was
never party to such a conversation and
no such tape exists but then the next
day Tuesday as you know the recording
was released we've heard a recording we
heard a tape of exactly the conversation
that Katrina Pierson just hours earlier
denied ever having been party to once
again confirming that she's a bold-faced
unabashed liar so FoxNews does what I
think is actually the right thing which
is they bring her back and then ed Henry
says hey here's what you said yesterday
then this tape got released it seems
you're not telling the truth so we're
gonna go through this in pieces here is
my challenge to you try to follow what
she's saying that's it it's a very
simple challenge try to even understand
the recursive and obvious lies that she
tells here let's start digging into it
so apparently Omar Omar Rosa was
watching us last night because I
understand it's got an email that she
told Trevor Noah at the Daily Show she
heard you tell me you knew nothing about
conference call talking about whether
the president used an n-word you said
this was a movie script so she says she
released at least one of these audio
tapes to show you lied to us well look
first of all that's not true as well so
there are two things that occurred last
night in our disco
you would read for me a book EPS excerpt
that I had not seen because her book had
not come out yet and you referenced me
having been speaking to the president
about this issue and that is false okay
so let's let's stop right there so right
away she's reading this written
statement and she miss reads it and she
talks about an ex Turk and she tries to
change the discussion from whether she
had a conference call about Trump's
n-word news use to whether she spoke to
Trump about his n-word use this is the
theme answering questions that were not
actually asked by Ed Henry commenting on
things that Henry doesn't even mention
and Edie Henry bless him he tries to
short-circuit it and he decides to jump
in and play the clip from the previous
night but see if you can even follow
this nonsense okay so let me get to the
facts I don't I don't want to get to
side issues bottom line is you saying
there's one call with Jason Miller one
without Jason Miller let's get to Miller
in a second the one without Jason Miller
on CBS Omarosa says according to a
transcript you provided me a part they
have not aired yet Omarosa says yeah
it's out there meaning the n-word tape
it's just in Katrina Pierson cuts in
yeah he said it ah bleep okay that is a
rough roughly what she said in the book
that you cursed as I asked you last
night and you said he said it he used
the n-word you denied that to me
absolutely you know why because I'm
refuting a claim that Omarosa made and
I'll say it again on Chuck Todd and
Savannah Guthrie let's not talk about
Chuck Todd let's talk about this pardon
me I'm gonna be polite to you but no no
no I'm not gonna do some issues pardon
me
and Henry's trying right I mean he is
trying to not let her talk about other
shows and other things because he
doesn't want to talk about that stuff he
wants an answer to here's how Alma Rosa
described your participation in her book
and it matches up exactly to the
transcript of the release tape that we
now have and you've been denying all of
it all along these are obvious lies and
she just wants to talk about other
things and it continues take a look no
no I'm
he said he said it absolutely not what
we were talking about that is not the
question that you were asking me this
was in regards to a specific discussion
check the tapes of what she said on
Chuck Todd and Savannah Guthrie she
specifically said that I said and
confirmed that Donald Trump said a
derogatory term on a conference call
with Jason Miller that did not happen
today what happened what happened today
is Omarosa submitted two different tapes
to CBS I'm not gonna get sidetracked but
we have to we're not I will admit
there's two tips I'm gonna explain it
would almost be better to just deny
having been on Fox News on Monday right
when he says listen you were on here
last night and you said she should say I
wasn't on this show I just I wasn't here
isn't Fox News supposed to be a safe
space for these people apparently not
it's the minimum it's just hey you were
on and you said this it's the
obfuscation and then he read Henry he
tries to get really direct he points out
that at one point she said she admitted
that Trump used the n-word but it was
just to move on okay
can you imagine that admitting that the
boss used the n-word about black people
even though they really didn't because
you just wanted to get on to another
topic of conversation who would do that
and if that's true that should be the
discussion so here's the next portion of
this I'm gonna lead this discussion and
it the fact of the matter is today you
clarified and said no I just said yes he
moved he used the n-word because I
wanted to move the conversation along
that was a discussion okay there's
multiple discussions why don't you if
that's the truth why didn't you tell me
and you know I don't know all the
details of this book I haven't seen it
but I did say yes he used the n-word to
move the conversation along I was about
this conference call with Jason Miller
the answer is no that was not said the
transcript is right here both calls that
said the first call that you're talking
about where she's claiming that I said
that was in a totally different call
where she was arguing with Lynn about
the existence of this let me explain
some bits you
Rosa has been using this tape to
manipulate people she is a bully she is
pushy she has a dog with a bone with
this let's go to facts and not attacks
this is just unconscionable and once
again she's there trying to defend the
indefensible as I said earlier she might
as well have just denied that she ever
made any claims or even appeared on fox
news because it's just as unbelievable
and then she goes into what works for
Trump which is not only criticizing and
smearing Omarosa but even criticizing
her and smearing her with the same word
dog let's look at just a little bit of
this let's get to the substance on that
call you say in your statement today
that basically we were just sifting
through rumors and the Jason Miller call
he was a campaign aide in fact we have
the transcript that you provided okay
and here's what is on the tape Jason
Miller says it's kind of tough to go out
and draft something meaning a statement
about whether the president use the
n-word
when you don't even know what the
context is you know I hate to start
emailing stuff around when we're just
not that sifting through rumors guess
what Katrina Pearson says yes it's true
so you were that's true you don't want
to go around making these accusations
I'm coming up with say mrs. drew it was
very true just miss Corder yourself you
just said I said that's true no you said
it's true
this is the best Katrina Pierson comes
in okay she hands a transcript of the
call it's her transcript hurt her
reading of the call to Ed Henry II D
Henry reads it and says here's what your
transcript says you said she goes that's
not what I said
Katrina it's your transcript there is no
more shame than this and this is part of
you know the alternative fact stuff the
post truth era call it whatever you want
she could have started at the beginning
and said you know I don't remember such
a conversation right I just I just don't
remember it could the conversation I
have a million conversations during the
campaign she could have said almost
anything but instead she said that
conversation I was never party to such a
conversation and you know that Trump's
gonna add insult to injury too right
he's going to scold her for not
defending him well enough or not denying
that Trump
used the n-word strongly enough for
getting caught in these web of lies well
you have to assume she knows Trump is
watching and at some point at some point
we'll see it and by the way side note if
you look at this clip I just played for
you on Fox News's YouTube channel the
comments are just slamming at Henry as
if he's the problem here and not the
unabashed lying reality and truth do not
matter anymore I have for you today one
of the dumbest political news cycle
stories of the last 72 hours and it has
been drama between Democratic candidate
for the house Alexandria Acacio Cortes
and right-wing radio host Ben Shapiro
I know Ben I've never had any contact
with Alexander Acacio Cortez and with
peace and love I'm telling you both of
their contributions to this drama have
been really really dumb and if you
haven't heard about this I'll give you
the 60 second summary uh Ben Shapiro
offered Alexandria Acacio Cortes a
$10,000 donation to either the charity
of her choice or to her campaign now
it's sort of an unusual offer the idea
of saying to a candidate for a position
I'll donate to your campaign if you
debate me but it's fine for ben shapiro
to make that offer if he wants the
legality of the $10,000 campaign
contribution of course appears to be not
legal the limit is $2,700 but okay I
guess it could be 2,700 to her campaign
and you know the rest who charity of her
choice in any case Alexandria didn't
reply she didn't say yes or no she
simply didn't reply which is perfectly
fine for her to do she has no
responsibility to reply to Ben Shapiro
she's running for Congress he's a
right-wing radio host she can do
whatever the hell she wants or nothing
at all when she is offered a debate
period but then Alexandria Acacio Cortes
likened Ben Shapiro's request that she
reply to cat calling on the street as
sometimes happens as often happens as
happens all the time all over this
country and all over the world she said
on Twitter just like cat calling I don't
owe a response to unsolicited requests
from men with bad intentions and also
like cat calling for some reason they
feel entitled to one
this is very silly okay she's right she
owes Ben Shapiro nothing and she's not
saying that expecting a response is the
same as a cat call she's saying
expecting a response to the debate
invitation is like expecting a response
to cat calling but why are we even
talking about cat calling and I made a
tweet about this over the weekend and I
ended up deleting it because I got
jumped all over by people on the left
saying David it's have you heard of
simile have you heard of analogy it's
not the same as cat calling expecting
the response is similar to I kind of
regret having deleted the tweet I
reflect reflexively did it and I always
say you really just shouldn't delete
tweets and for a second I thought oh man
I must have really missed worded this
let me just delete it and start over I
regret doing that now but a lot of
people saying it's not the same as he's
not saying it's the same as cat calling
fine but even bringing up cat calling D
values criticisms of actual cat calling
that takes place so here it's already
gotten really dumb in my opinion but
then ben shapiro jumps back in with
something that's just as dumb calling
the mention of cat calling a slander of
him okay he tweeted discussions and
debate are not bad intentions slandering
someone as a sexist cat caller without
reason or evidence does demonstrate
cowardice and bad intent however once
again slander colloquially is making
false and damaging statements about
someone slander legally is making false
and damaging statements about someone
that are rise to the level of I don't
know I guess you would call it civil
liability in some case Alexandria Acacio
Cortez didn't slander Shapiro or
anything close to it she didn't even say
he is a cat caller or he is like a cat
caller she said the expectation of a
response is like the expectation of a
response that cat callers may have it
was one dumb statement after another it
became this massive story Pat where
every media outlet jumps in and I'm sort
of glad that the timing was over the
weekend so that we had the ability to
let it all shake out
and see the dumb comments from both
sides instead of just commenting like on
her catcalling comment or just
commenting about the invitation which we
likely wouldn't have done the entire
thing now has now put together sort of
the totality of the picture and as you
can probably tell I don't care about her
not debating I don't care about her not
responding or the offer what's
interesting to me is how quickly it
devolves into nonsense statements from
both sides and as far as Shapiro is
concerned how can someone with a law
degree like him call it slander just
doesn't make any sense I think this
whole thing is a total gong show I don't
think Ben Shapiro should have made the
request in the first place I think it's
fine it certainly helps him in his brand
right and especially because Alexander
II Ocasio Cortese doesn't want to debate
him because you know at a time or
because she feels like that's just two
below her profile or it doesn't make him
look strong right or it doesn't
contribute to her winning her election
in the 14th district of New York right
yeah yeah perfectly reasonable
reasonable explanation for why she's not
going to do it and if Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes really just isn't interested in
debating Ben Shapiro she could have just
stayed silent on the matter right not
tweeted anything back at him and in the
meantime the hangers-on like
right-wingers candice owens and charlie
kirk if they jumped in and they said hey
we can get even more money together if
she'll do it or saying that they debate
her and again i ended up in the middle
of this on twitter i said listen I'll
debate any of these people nobody has to
pay anybody right hundreds of people
saying let let's do that Ben please
debate David or Candice please debate
David not a peep from any of them and
you know what they don't owe me a
response I'd be up for the debates but
they don't owe me a response well Ben
Ben Shapiro has been on for an interview
and the topic of gun control although it
has been some time since then and then
we heard from one of Charlie Kirk's
publicist - about yeah him on but that
kind of fizzled out yes it evaporated
into thin air sort of like Donald
Trump's foreign policy plan or whatever
analogy you want to make speaking of
race and race baiting and racism there
was an attempt at a follow up white
nationalist alt-right rally yesterday in
Washington DC you might remember a year
ago in Charlottesville Virginia there
was a horrible horrible white
supremacist white separatist all right
rally it led to the death of Heather
hire Heather hare I always say that in
correct attire it is higher I just never
remember what it is the president the
current President of the United States
said that there were very fine people on
both sides of that white nationalist
white supremacist alt-right rally in
Charlottesville Virginia a year ago
we're now at the one-year anniversary
and of course this is exactly the type
of event we would remember with a moment
of silence not another white nationalist
rally but there were white nationalists
who wanted another rally so they were
going to do it this weekend they were
gonna do it Sunday and in terms of
turnout it failed hilariously and
miserably apparently somewhere between a
couple dozen and fifty actual outright
white nationalist supporters showed up
there were way more counter protesters
and police officers and even just media
people covering it way out numbering the
actual white nationalist alt rightists
and I want to sort of make the point
that just because there was low turnout
at this event doesn't mean that there's
no longer white supremacy that has been
reinvigorated by the presidency of
Donald Trump it doesn't mean that
there's no longer horrible vile people
in this country they didn't show up to
the rally but that doesn't mean that
they don't exist and of course we know
they exist and we know that they've been
emboldened by the presidency of Donald
Trump we actually had someone on the
ground there Joshua Turner who you might
remember because he's a former neo-nazi
who I've interviewed on the show he's
part of an organization called saved by
reason and he emailed me and he said
quote about 50 unites the right guys
came and there were over 10,000 counter
protesters the police had them separated
and everything went down peacefully I
filmed with newsy the entire time got to
talk to some neo-nazis one on one
they were happy the protests turned out
peacefully but they were basically
drowned out from the counter protesters
and left early the second it started to
drizzle so it rained on their parade
literally and that was about it so it
was a failure it was a failure in terms
of being the sort of public show of
support for all right ISM or white
nationalism or whatever I find the most
interesting thing about this entire
one-year anniversary rally to be how me
I was unsure about if and how they
should cover it
of course right-wing media mostly
provided cover for the fact that this
was a white supremacist rally so a
couple of examples of that least power
from Media Matters had some funny
lower-third screenshots from Fox &
Friends where they forgot to mention
that it was a white nationalist rally
one lower third during Fox and Friends
said and Tifa demands an end to America
they had another headline and Tifa
protesters chant no borders in DC what
about the fact that it was white
nationalists commemorating
Charlottesville where a woman died yeah
apparently they couldn't be expected to
do that okay so that was one thing and
we sort of expected that coverage from
right-wing media but the more
interesting thing is that there is a
debate about should we deep platform
white nationalists versus should we
challenge them on their ideas and
interview them this is a debate we've
dealt with a lot because of my
interviews with all kinds of extremists
the Westboro Baptist Church white
nationalists Richard Spencer homophobes
racists so on and so forth and the
debate that is had is usually the wrong
debate the debate is usually David these
people should not be interviewed period
or merely interviewing them exposes
their bad ideas I believe that the
responsible approach is what Steven
Vanel ii also known to some of you is
destiny in the online gaming world calls
responsible platforming which means if
you interview the racists or the
extremists or whoever you have to
understand it's not always obvious to
the audience that their ideas are bad
racist discriminatory i the ideas they
want to do the interview because they
want any platform to be used to get
these ideas out there and maybe someone
will be convinced by their ideas so
simply saying to them tell me why you're
a racist tell me why Jews are the
problem in all of the world whatever and
having them tell you why that doesn't
expose them that's not responsible
platforming responsible platforming
means you're prepared to challenge their
ideas not in a screaming and yelling way
we
yelling scream on this program but with
thoughtful well-crafted questions where
you've researched what they're likely
responses are going to be so that you
can interrupt their use of your platform
for propaganda purposes that's what I
try to do I don't think I always succeed
Pat at least not as well as I want to
but there's this middle ground between
they should be completely deep
platformed and we pretend their ideas
don't exist that doesn't work because
that actually can provide cover for
their ideas to to catalyze and to
metastasize the other side is just
interviewing them is bad for them
because it exposes their bad ideas
responsible platforming is the path
forward yeah I mean I think in most
corporate outlets the reporters will
either try to go for the gotcha question
to catch them in like some soundbite
that's not gonna play out well for them
sure or they don't know which questions
to ask and they don't know how to push
them effectively because they're not
used to asking very pressing questions
admit if they're interviewing a
politician they don't want to say
something that will cause them access in
the future so it's more about practice
than anything else yeah they don't want
to lose access and I think that that is
a big priority for how corporate media
handles interviews with big politicians
and and bigger names and I think that
that is it's sort it's it's a false
debate that was mostly had around this
it's not so much about whether to
interview the extremists but about how
to interview them interviewing them in
and of itself isn't what needs to be
debated how it should be done is the
important conversation and a lot of
bogus discussions centered around this
rally send me your thoughts how do you
define responsible platforming I'm on
twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
twitter at david pakman show let's talk
about Laura Ingraham she has a show on
Fox News the program has been repulsive
and revolting for a long time that's not
news the most recent time we talked
about Laura Ingraham it was when she
equated child internment camps for
immigrant children to summer camps that
was about I guess it was about a month
or two ago but now it's been taken to a
new level because Ingraham is spouting
straight-up white nationalism in
primetime on Fox News I've often talked
about code that's used to bait people
this kind of relates to our conversation
at the top of the show about race
baiting so if you
some political savvy you don't
straight-up say black and brown people
are horrible and are destroying our
country you speak and double entendre as
you say the values we hold dear are at
risk as a result of immigration from
underprivileged parts of the world right
you word it in a way where you're kind
of hiding behind language you don't say
uncontrolled gun ownership is fine
except when it's black people no you
don't say it that way you say
enforcement of gun laws must focus on
low-income populations in urban areas
who are obtaining guns specifically to
commit crimes right or again however you
want to phrase it Laura Ingraham went on
a rant about demographic changes
destroying our country and this is one
of the features of the Trump era and I
call it a feature because Trump is like
this it's now more acceptable in the
milieu of the 2018 trumpets to say
straight up a lot of the things you used
to feel some shame about saying and you
would hide behind ambiguity or double
meanings here's Laura Ingraham straight
up saying America no longer exists
because of demographic changes as a
result of both illegal and legal
remember they used to say that legal
immigration is fine legal immigration is
also part of why we've lost America
because in some parts of the country it
does seem like the America that we know
and love doesn't exist anymore massive
demographic changes have been foisted
upon the American people and their
changes that none of us have were voted
for and most of us don't like from
Virginia to California we see stark
examples of how radically in some ways
the country has changed now much of this
is related to both illegal and in some
cases legal immigration that of course
progressives love so they run b-roll
over her shoulder of Hispanics
harvesting food she wouldn't eat if it
weren't for those illegal and legal
immigrants that she claims to be so
concerned about they literally put up
the b-roll that proves why these
individuals are so important to the
United States being the United States of
America
listen to what she's saying America as
we know it no longer exists because of
demographic changes brought on by
immigration cut the doublespeak
demographic changes means a lower
percentage of white people due to a
higher percentage of non-white people
when she says because of immigration
that is saying America is no longer what
it once was it's no longer real America
because there's too many brown people
that have come in the people who are
single handedly supporting her eating
food and assimilating nutrition and
nutrients so that she can remain alive
yeah she says it doesn't seem like the
America we know it sounds kind of like
an observation rather than her making a
point if she was to make a point then
she'd have to go into the statistics of
you know the population of white people
declining but she doesn't even want to
get into that you know wants to make it
about feeling and the most important
element of this is the word foisted the
word foisted demographic changes have
been foisted upon America to foist is to
impose something that's unwelcome right
most of the immigration to the US has
been legal in accordance with the laws
of the country when white people came
from Europe and came to what is now the
United States and killed endless Native
Americans that is demographic change
foisted upon a population violently so
people moving to the US like they've
moved to the US since the beginning of
the country is not the violent voice
things she's trying to frame what she's
saying did happen it just isn't over the
last 20 years because of people coming
from Latin America to work in the
restaurant industry and in the
agriculture industry and of course in
every industry including medicine and
law and everything else it's how the
country was created there was
demographic change foisted upon the
people who were already in the country
and it's called when white people came
here and killed Native Americans and by
the way I mentioned this she mentions
that both illegal and legal immigrants
are part of the problem I thought
Republicans were still claiming they
only are against illegal immigration I
guess she's now including both of those
and I don't know how this woman has a
single sponsor left at this point she's
saying she wants a white country she's
saying the real America is a white
America and we've lost that and
apparently Fox News I guess tacitly is
okay with this one of the top three
cable networks in the country is
not reacting to what she said I guess
they like it yeah and also laura
ingraham does have three adopted
children from foreign countries oh one
from Russia two from Russia and one from
Guatemala I wonder how they would feel
about this I'm sure
unfortunately I'm sure that they are
completely brainwashed by Laura Ingraham
if they're even old enough to be I have
no idea about any of these individuals
but you know making the argument that
she couldn't possibly be racist because
she has a Hispanic daughter or son
that's called identity politics and I
thought that they were against that so
I'd be curious to see whether she makes
that argument discuss this with us on
our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash re d di t if you are a
pro-business republican you probably
have at some point said that
corporations should be able to make the
decisions that are best for them except
of course when it is about people
protesting police brutality in which
case i guess the president should be
allowed to tell businesses that those
people should be suspended or that it is
him who wants to or it is he I guess I
would say who wants to be doing visa
spending and if that sounds confusing to
you it's because it is Donald Trump
tweeted that protesting NFL players who
don't stand for the national anthem
should be suspended without pay he said
quote the NFL players are added again
taking a knee when they should be
standing proudly for the national anthem
numerous players from different teams
wanted to show their outrage at
something that most of them are unable
to define they make a fortune doing what
they love be happy be cool a football
game that fans are paying so much money
to watch and enjoy is no place to
protest most of that money goes to the
players anyway find another way to
protest stand proudly for your national
anthem or be with capital letters
suspended without pay
so what I'm trying to understand here is
whether Trump is saying he's going to
direct teams to suspend players without
pay or is he saying he can suspend
players without pay who work not for him
or the government but for NFL teams
what's he actually saying here Trump
weights are like poetry they're open to
many different interpretations and we
can all have different conclusions about
him unfortunately the law also has an
interpretation of what Donald Trump is
suggesting and what he's suggesting is
actually illegal 18 US Code subsection
227 called wrongfully influencing a
private entities employment decisions by
a member of Congress says that nobody
who is an agent of the government
whether it's Trump or a member of
Congress the executive branch whoever
can influence companies like the NFL to
take action like the suspension of
individual players and this has become a
completely partisan issue and it's
actually one of those partisan issues
that serves the power system that
maintains the two-party duopoly and I
it's this is important right if your
philosophy underlying your politics is
that corporations should be free to do
what they want barring that it's illegal
and do what is best for them then the
President of the United States should
not be directing companies or
threatening to suspend people himself
but the the issue is here that this is
one of those distracted on topics right
when Trump wants to take attention away
from the constant contradictions of Rudy
Giuliani his lawyer or from the complete
disaster that is going on in the Paul
Manafort trial or from whatever this is
one of those things that he can go back
to and I actually want want to take it a
step further because we've got to be
able to think and and walk at the same
time or chew gum and walk at the same
time statements are official acts when
the president makes a statement it's an
official act a tweet is a statement okay
so merely tweeting that the NFL should
suspend players without pay when they
kneel during the national anthem that is
all arguably illegal however this is a
really effective way of riling people up
and distracting them the national anthem
the Pledge of Allegiance these are all
distractions NFL players are of course
not government employees Trump can't
find them
he can't reprimand them but when you
talk about kneeling NFL players
particularly in early August when there
isn't
football season going on yet this
distracts from that Russia meeting or
the neo-nazis that commemorated the
one-year anniversary of the
Charlottesville rally or whatever else
this is something that makes it really
difficult for people because this isn't
nothing
but it is a distraction from really
important issues yeah that's exactly it
is it's an distract a thon especially
because there's no real update to this
NFL kneeling controversy story in every
new season has started up but it's not
like the NFL has changed its policy yeah
so he's just making this move to play to
his base and it does work for him it
does and you know kneeling in this way
is speech Trump is saying that there
should be a punishment for a particular
type of speech and he is the government
doing it right so that this really is a
danger but it's also important not to
get so sucked in that you forget about
all the other issues that Trump is
actively distracting and serving out
disinformation from